I learned in the documentary that Joe
DiMaggio was kind of a mentor to you he
came to you and said hey let me tell you
about my life in other words he was
giving he wasn't a hostile guy he was a
good guy with a lot of guys like that
um Joe didn't say much uh Mickey Mantle
didn't say much
Yogi probably said more on anybody and
he said it with yogi-isms all the time
you mentioned yogaisms do you have one
that sticks out so Yogi's 75 80. that's
what I am now and he's getting dressed
next to me there's a locker between he
and I Whitey has a Locker on the other
side and so right and so Yogi is is
putting his pants on and uh I said yo
you know when you guys travel did you
stay in their first class hotels and and
was it uh you know what was it like and
he said uh oh yeah yeah Reggie um you
know when we went play the White Sox
over there uh and then uh you know at a
windy city
um
if we stayed in the region so tall I
said you're mean to say everybody said
yeah yeah
you know what I mean and um he says I
really like the hotel it was really nice
the only thing was is the towels were so
thick I couldn't hardly get them in my
suitcase to get them home
[Music]
unbelievable
one other one I gotta say is we're
standing on a foul line uh Old-Timers
Day all the greats come out and every
year they would run scroll during the
national anthem when they were planning
we stand there of the players that had
passed on the people we had lost and
you'd see people 50 years old you know
young and you'd go like wow
uh I didn't know that guy passed away so
young and so Yogi is standing next to me
and he's
putting his elbow in my ribs and I say
Yogi the the camera is probably on us
you know you know the anthem and he
keeps going going and I said well what
do you want and so you'll these are the
people that have died so Yogi says boy
you know I hope I don't ever see my name
up there
that's the greatest